hacía dos años que no se reunían de
forma presencial los líderes de más de
100 estados inauguraron la asamblea
general de la onu nueva york en un clima
de tensión creciente entre potencias que
preocupa a naciones unidas pero que
desde eeuu se ha intentado desmentir
mostrando un carácter más
multilateralista
no buscamos una nueva guerra fría o un
mundo dividido en bloques rígidos
eeuu está listo para trabajar con
cualquier nación que dé un paso adelante
y busca una resolución pacífica para
compartir desafíos incluso si tenemos
intensos desacuerdos pero no todos están
de acuerdo en dialogar fuera de la sede
de la onu decenas de personas exigieron
a la casa blanca no negociar con el
nuevo presidente iraní ebrahim raisi
además de la geopolítica los otros
protagonistas de esta primera jornada
fueron el 19 y el cambio climático los
desafíos que para el secretario general
de la onu se están abordando de forma
incorrecta
el cob y la crisis climática han
expuesto profundas fragilidades de las
sociedades y como planeta sin embargo en
lugar de humildad frente a estos
desafíos épicos vemos arrogancia y en
lugar de solidaridad pasiva estamos en
un callejón sin salida hacia la
destrucción tú destruction naciones
unidas alertó recientemente sobre el
fracaso mundial en la desaceleración del
cambio climático y lleva meses
denunciando la desigualdad que existe en
la provisión de vacunas en los países
más pobres